[Music]
Hollywood on the run from multiple
wildfires raging in Southern California
take a look at this the frightening
video that went viral today of cars
driving right beside a massive blaze
that's like a scene out of a disaster
movie but it is all too real and Kevin
Frazier is the on location of the fire
burning out of control
cast Nancy we are inside a gated
neighborhood in bel-air this is some of
the priciest property in LA and is also
where many of the stars that you know
and love live now let me just show you
how chaotic it's been if you look up
behind me there's one structure that's
already burned and another one over
there it is very smoky this has been a
very dangerous and stressful day here in
Hollywood la is on fire anchor Rob Lowe
posted this dramatic video of his
commute home and told his fans we are
safe others aren't pray for them this
morning actress Lea Michele was
evacuated from her Brentwood home she
posted this video from her car before
hitting the red carpet at an event for
The Hollywood Reporter thank God for
this event this morning because I got up
at 5:30 and everyone came to the house
and they're like we need to leave and so
threw my cat in the bag and left you
have to take a moment to pray for people
to send out good vibes it's tragic Annie
my daughter lives in Studio City and
it's getting closer and closer Real
Housewife Kyle Richards wore a mask and
instagrammed herself getting Ash off her
car's windshield her husband Hollywood
real estate agent Mauricio Umansky says
their home featured on the reality show
is in a mandatory evacuation zone we
still have a lot of our belongings in
our house that we're selling we do have
some people living in the house and we
asked them to grab some of our photos
and some of our personal stuff the fires
are also impacting production of movies
and TV shows filming was suspended
yesterday on HBO's Westworld which
shoots in Santa Clarita
we're told the show is scheduled to
resume shooting today but quote the
production will have a fire safety
officer on set to monitor conditions
throughout the day Jeffrey Wright who
stars on the show posted video after
being evacuated
yesterday and also in northern Los
Angeles production on CBS's SWAT was
suspended one of its star Shamar more
Instagram from his backyard can hear
that helicopter coming you know why
because la is a mess wherever you are
stay safe count your blessings Lionel
Richie who lives in bel-air cancelled
his Vegas show tonight
he says he's quote helping family
evacuate to a safer place and Lionel is
a very smart man because we are not that
far away from his ex-wife's home and as
you can see this is one of the
structures that the firefighters could
not save Nancy it's gonna be a long
night and a tough day tomorrow
it sure is hopefully everyone stays safe
Kevin thank you very much
[Music]